muchas gracias con limitación de nuevo
bueno yo creo que justamente este
ascenso de la izquierda y además de la
extrema derecha responde a una a un
pueblo a una ciudadanía bastante cansada
sobre todo durante este periodo de ccoo
bits
y se ha vivido en francia muy bien el
mundo en general durante estos 23 años y
pues justamente ahora con las nuevas
medidas con la posición que está
teniendo mal una macro como respecto al
conflicto en ucrania
a sí mismo pues yo pienso que de una
opción de forma así no es tan deseable
obviamente para el partido de macrón la
obra pública en marcha que obviamente
ellos no llegan a ellos no hayan llegado
a ser mayoría absoluta dentro de la
asamblea nacional pero creo que sí es
saludable para la democracia en que en
que haya diferentes partidos y
diferentes fuerzas políticas que puedan
dirigir el destino de esta república y
en medio de esta división que quedó en
las legislativas con una extrema derecha
fortalecida una izquierda bastante
precedente y también el partido
oficialista la república en marcha que
alianzas tendrá que hacer más como para
poder que la asamblea nacional apruebe
sus proyectos del eje
claro pues evidentemente una de las
primeras alianzas que se van a realizar
va a ser con el partido republicano y
creo que puede ser aquí aquí hay una
situación tira gana dañando joongang
ganadores los dos porque claro macro
para poder leer este no tan
significativo número de escaños de votos
para que pasen las leyes
para que puedan gobernar justamente
estos estos 5 años y también en los
republicanos van a tener cierta
influencia en el gobierno en quizá poner
algún algunos ministros o bueno alguien
dentro dentro del gobierno una de las
preguntas que había en estas elecciones
es que podía pasar con el primer
ministro actualmente es elisa elizabeth
bones nombrada por mayo pero la
constitución dice que el primer ministro
debe ser nombrado según el respaldo de
la asamblea general y si la izquierda
ganaba una mayoría por encima de la de
mayo se hablaba incluso de que me la
acción podría ser el primer ministro
esto finalmente no sucedió que podría
pasar ahora deberá cambiar su primera
ministra
sinceramente ella ya depende bastante de
manera que las agrupaciones políticas
puedan llegar a ciertos aciertos a una
cierta armonía en un acertado yo creo
que va a quedar en conversaciones entre
ellos definitivamente como mencionaste
un gran sector de la población y sobre
todo la lupe lario que esperaba llegar a
ser el primer ministro pero pues como
como mencionas al final el partido en la
agrupación nubes no llegó a tener esta
cantidad de votos suficientes para
para posicionarlo dentro del juego
político pero creo que igual van a
incluir una bandeja suficiente
influencia dentro del gobierno de estos
cinco años entonces todavía tenemos que
dar y ahora hablemos de un escenario más
internacional esta división que tendrá
más como para gobernar internamente como
impactará en la unión europea y
específicamente en el papel que tenía
francia en la guerra de ucrania
[Música]
definitivamente estos cinco años han
sido unos cinco años bastantes
favorecedores para macro porque como
hemos comentado anteriormente ellos
contaban con la mayoría absoluta en el
antiguo parlamento con 260 y 62 escaños
y justamente estos seis meses esperanza
eso me dio la presidencia del consejo
europeo por lo tanto ha estado ha tenido
obviamente un fuerte protagonismo a
nivel europeo han estado hablando de
temas que obviamente le conviene han
estado dirigiendo el agenda europea
durante estos seis meses y que
justamente acaba ahora el 30 de julio y
bueno pues además además en términos de
relaciones internacionales etcétera
sabemos que francia que sobre todo el
presidente macro tiene cierta influencia
dentro del
conflicto en ucrania dentro de rusia
entonces
depende bastante de con la manera en
cómo él lo va a direccionar